hello I'm Sarah I play Tom Lane OMB
have enough damage to clean it up the
chaos drum does a lot of damage but at
me just clean up Phoenix one that's
three soon-to-be four members day first
time I play League of Legends it was
2012 February the Walgreens cream was
just ruler wasn't released so he was
like really really long time ago
somehow my friends just after the lady's
little release so oh this game is so
cool you have to play so I just started
I played Nidalee a since level one until
to 2k yellow I was like one trick pony
champion first time the reason I
starting like considering the be a pro
gamer is a in amateur I was in the same
team as a rocks curl so he be uh pro
first time so he joined the like I am
first time after I say oh it was so good
cuz like show to like all the peoples
I'm good I'm good skilled players like
that so I want to be saying I'll talk
about player the game
I actually thinks Sheriff is number one
right now every parents doesn't like
your your child played like games or
something
so first time they refused it but after
Bo III be a probe they they just like
completely like understanding so you
know it's fine
all my friends like really really Julius
to me cuz I used to play well every
every PC game every video games like
so but they even like your surprise
because they all my friends like
expecting you you're gonna lose you're
gonna take her money with game like this
the reason why I decided to come to na
because right after I leaving the
lodging as a sub I I lost like almost my
passion as a game I saw the like article
CLG looking for the new top laners and I
saw it and my brother we like recommend
to me oh just they're looking for Tom
Manor and why don't you just go any is
he asked me and is it okay I lost my
passion in Korea so I won't be like a
fresh experience there was like good
team ace in theology so but it was not
that like completely good season she
considered themselves contenders for
first place and we're looking ahead to
the World Championships but now both
teams have just gone through a tough
quarterfinal series and they might feel
like they've hit rock bottom
above my criticism as a sales you know
they see elders Tom nine yards off you
know coz gotta like for Doc season
during I joined an so probably I have a
problem too but it's like I guess his
team games so if you if your team being
like going too low everyone has a
problem like this I know I had a fault
but it was not like completely my fault
okay we have like capricious before I
drink even deeper I doing their faces
all their inhibitors are up right now
one could go down to the way that super
minions up top but they have
oh my gosh pour down syrup can't do
anything doctor I leading the CLG I I
was I want you to keep playing on na so
I didn't want to like go back to Korea
or going to China or something at that
time TDK over me as a we have a we are
gonna play as a five Koreans like that
even though it's NACS there was there
was commit for me because I wanted to
play in a name I a little bit of like
miss miss thing about like Koreans and
they're like practice or you know
environment or something so I chose
flash but here comes Sarah P really
wants Wolfie clash comes a crowd get
some thank you very much a one-for-one
when we ninja coming to join the TDK I
recommend him to these guys good we have
to like bro him after I play with him I
realize he's a really good player and he
is good really good mechanic and we have
a good synergy together so I really like
it's gonna be sneaky looking for win
number two they can stop cloud 9
forgetting
I really here's your respect as a team
and I really loved a team so I want to
really be a showing the coop performance
in LCS but stuck at VJ shoe so I was
really upset like during entice and
tired of season renegades comeback nine
to twelve forty three minutes in
renegades takedown echo fox four wins in
their last five games I joined the
renegade cuz I had not much pressure
because after after I screams we I I
just realized hundred percent really not
going to relegate it so we're gonna stay
in LCS so I just completely like like
comfortable as a playing as yes and I
enjoy there's this second we in a row
for renegades and they are just one game
away from rejoining the North American
LCS
first I really really surprised about
the fries because phrase is the best
case we carry since I have a team
teammates so I really impressive about
him skills after the roster changes I I
dislike the roster so I consider a
question during the leading the team
after MB bode and they offer me a good
like good offer and they they they said
we were gonna like prepare the girl
rosters so I believed them and I joined
the team good stuff from Andy to close
it out they had a good team comp they
played to their win conditions
I love the bill from Sarah really really
smart I have to say he knew what he
needed to get done as a team right now
Tim MB all five members are kind of like
good in individual skills good mechanics
and we are gonna like keep keep stacking
our like relationship and teamwork so we
are going I think we are going to do
well as a pro-gamer my ultimate goal is
uh I just desire to winning until I lost
my passions so they say